hey what's up I'm Ryan Oxenberg I'm a
writer-director right off the top I
wanted to thank film courage for giving
me the opportunity to share with you
some directing lessons that I learned
making damage control damage control is
about a man who surprises his fiancee
with a new property and he's forced to
confront his past behavior
it's a classic morality play about karma
coming around in the vein of the
twilight zone I've been making movies
since I was a kid
I used to have one of those Indiglo stop
watches and I would get all of my toys
together and create these epics and then
I would look at the watch I'd hit stop
in three hours would have passed I would
then go to a notepad and write down what
those stories were I've always been
engaged in making movies I've made short
films I've made documentaries I've shot
things for nonprofits more of like the
corporate thing the bread-and-butter
thing but I've also always been writing
I've optioned scripts I've been hired to
adopt novels I write with people I write
for people directing is the most fun
that keep makes me feel the most alive I
love being on my feet I love
problem-solving in the moment and to do
that you'd think I'm gonna prepare that
night before your shoe you prepare like
crazy
I just break down the shots make my shot
list I imagine myself in the location I
write down little things I'm gonna
whisper in the actors ears I am a
hundred in ten percent prepared but on
damage control what I didn't prepare for
was being unprepared now I wanted to ask
you have you ever been in a situation
onset where this unforeseeable thing
happens and now everything's in disarray
and you're panicking because you may not
have your movie you may not make your
day the biggest lesson that I've learned
in I would say I am still learning is
how to be what I call a
malleable director a director that could
roll with all the punches you have to
take what the film gods throw at you it
forces you any sort of restriction to be
creative and who knows what could come
out of it maybe there's a gift on the
other end of that the first thing that I
learned on damage control about being a
malleable director is letting go of the
script I had to show the whole history
of a relationship up until this moment
in eight minutes on set I realized that
we didn't have in the writing what this
relationship was because we scrambled
over in the writing not to have any
expository information about them that's
not interesting what's interesting is
letting actors be in the moment in play
and convey to us what the dialogue
didn't about who they are
Elia Kazan said that the directing is in
the casting and if you cast great people
that's who your character is the next
lesson on being a malleable director is
sail with the wind not against it we had
10 hours to shoot 10 pages over two days
and it was all in available light so
myself the cinematographer and each in
the Griffin Electric Joseph 10 we
strategically plan the order that we're
gonna shoot things because damage
control takes place in a single moment
it's Alison's lunch break
when Drew surprises her with this new
property the second day we shot out all
the shacks stuff we reserved the entire
morning for it and we were early it went
over brilliantly but now we had an hour
and a half until lunch so I was like -
Andy let's shoot this now oh no it
doesn't match before let's shoot this
the light's not right we got to shoot it
later and we were wasting time looking
at the monitor and seeing the shots that
we shot yesterday if they
matched how the light looked now and
that would determine which shot we would
set up next and then I started worrying
like oh we have to move all of our gear
this way and then that way I didn't know
what to shoot
we spent a half hour talking about what
we could have done and what I neglected
to do was like okay let's shoot the
inserts so you have to learn how to just
throw away your schedule and be a good
editor in your head you need to take
tally of all the things that you had
shot up until then and be able to piece
it all together in your head because now
you're shooting it piecemeal it's just
important as a director is now if you're
shooting things out of the order the
actors anticipated perhaps they didn't
do the preparation for that scene or
they didn't lead themselves up
emotionally to it it's up to you to be
the compass and guide them back to where
they need to be another phase in
production where I learned to be a more
malleable director is in editing in my
rough cut I was just using medium closes
of onna in the shock I didn't use any of
the whites and I was pretty committed to
it
I loved the vulnerability that she could
express on her face without saying
anything I just had an idea of what she
had been through and what she is trying
to communicate to drew in the shack and
what I did was I was cutting just two
close-ups of her and then what I was
getting was a lack of mystery and this
came from the writers know he's like
keep on a back and I did and then it was
like I'm gonna build up to that close-up
shot I'm gonna find the best moment to
do it and I didn't it worked way better
you have to serve the story in the Edit
rather than the shots you love or the
movie that you
you had in your head before or else
you're gonna not work with natural
rhythms of what this movie is and you're
also going to be pretty down on yourself
because you have this expectation of
what it's supposed to be but it's really
this so you have to make this work I
used to be pretty rigid making my movies
I used to be pretty insular I used to
not share my rough cuts with friends I
used to be afraid to ask crew members
what does this mean or what does this do
and on damage control was the time where
I just completely let go and I'd like to
hear stories from you guys about gifts
great things that came out of problems
and how you solve them and how your
movie and yourself as a director
benefited from them I hope you guys
found this video helpful talking about
it is even helpful to me and working out
just how I approach directing and manage
my expectations but when all those
elements come together when the
performance is spot-on the camera
movement is spot-on the sound is gray
just everything is working operatic ly
and you're the conductor of it all
there's no other feeling like it
you